c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france 24 à
la une ce soir l'ouverture des assises
nationales en guinée des consultations
voulue par le président de la transition
mamadou doumbouya est boycotté par une
bonne partie de l'opposition nous serons
à conakry dans ce journal nous
poursuivons notre série en république
démocratique du congo notre envoyé
spécial bastien renouil accompagner l
armée ougandaise en opérations spéciales
sur le sol congolais nous irons
aujourd'hui dans le parc des virunga où
les militaires ougandais revendit
plusieurs victoires contre les adf
notre invité ce soir l'auteur et le
réalisateur françois demerliac il est
venu nous présenter son projet paroles
la mise en ligne d'entretiens exclusifs
de personnalités ayant joué un rôle
pendant la guerre d'algérie interview à
suivre à la fin de ce journal
on commence donc par l'ouverture de ces
assises en guinée une conférence de
réconciliation voulue par le chef de la
junte au pouvoir le colonel mamadou
doumbouya des assises présenté à par la
junte comme une occasion historique de
panser les plaies du passé trouble mais
qui sont largement boycottées par
l'opposition la correspondance à conakry
le mali diakité
quelques leaders politiques des membres
de la société civile des religieux des
diplomates accrédités en guinée ont
répondu à l'invitation du colonel
doumbia dans un discours d'une dizaine
de minutes le président de la transition
guinéenne a annoncé la mise en place
d'une commission de réconciliation
cette commission sera présidée par le
grand imam du pays mamadou saliou camara
et monseigneur vincent koulibaly
l'archevêque de conakry selon lui ce
sont ces religieux qui auront pour
mission en accord avec tous les
politiques du pays et acteurs de la
société civile pour déterminer la
démarche à suivre pour réconcilier les
guinéens et unis à l'organisation des
ces assises nationales
dénommée journée de vérité et parlons
pour ainsi donner une occasion
historique et unique aux guinéens de se
regarder en face bien en face les yeux
dans le jeu et de se parler franchement
à coeur ouvert cette fois ci la
rencontre boycotté par une soixantaine
de partis politiques il estime que la
tenue de ces assises n'est qu'une
stratégie pour l'agente de traîner le
pas pour organiser les élections c'est à
situation pas préparé pour les connaître
et a pas deux et de visibilité il y a
pas d'organisation réel sur
quoi nous devons aboutir pendant cette
période depuis six mois ils sont ici
gère le pays de leur manière sans
consulter personne pour ses politiques
comme pour nombreux observateurs de la
scène politique guinéenne
la priorité de la jante devrait plutôt
être l'annoncé de la durée de la
transition qui n'est toujours pas connue
la reprise du procès sankara au burkina
faso les et l'audience avait été
suspendue début mars après une requête
des avocats de la défense les avocats
des accusés ont la parole pour leurs
plaidoiries après trois semaines de
silence l'avocat du principal accusé le
général deviennent des réaffectant des
productions assistant sur la
prescription des faits reprochés à son
client
maxime mots comme ex chef d'une milice
anti ballack a arrêté à fin février et
remis à la cpi la semaine dernière a
subi sa première comparution devant la
cour pénale internationale
il est suspecté de crimes contre
l'humanité de crimes de guerre commis
lors de la guerre de 2013 2014 en
centrafrique le compte rendu de notre
correspondante à l'ail stéphanie maupas
maximum comme s'est très peu exprimé au
cours de cette audience un qui était
surtout destiné à vérifier son identité
et l'informer de ses droits mais c'est
via son avocat nick kaufman qu'il a
dénoncé ses conditions d'arrestation au
tchad fin février et ses conditions de
détention selon son avocat il aurait été
détenu dans une cellule insalubre sans
pouvoir communiquer avec ses proches
sans pouvoir contacter un avocat lors
cet ancien responsable des antilles
ballack a ensuite été transféré à la
cour pénale internationale puisque un
mandat d'arrêt secret confidentiel cour
est contre lui depuis décembre 2018 et
il a donc été incarcéré dans cette
prison la cour ici free running n à une
banlieue de la haye et dans cette prison
est bien il a retrouvé d'autres
responsables centrafricain puisque trois
3 autres personnalités sont aussi accusé
pour des crimes commis en centrafrique
et ils sont actuellement en cours de
procès nous vous emmenons hier dans le
nord kivu fous les forces armées
ougandaises chasse les miliciens adf
pour restaurer la sécurité dans l'est de
la république démocratique du congo
aujourd'hui nous vous proposons un
reportage aux côtés des soldats
ougandais dans le monde owens au riz
ainsi que dans la forêt du parc national
des virunga où il revendique plusieurs
victoires contre les groupes armés
reportage de bastien renouil
démonstration de force des soldats
ougandais devant notre caméra
pas d'ennemis repéré sur les membranes
taurisson jour là mais selon eux des
miliciens à dr sont bien retranchés
quelque part dans les montagnes
today is our kind et cela fait dix jours
que nous sommes un bateau b nous
effectuons nos patrouilles depuis sept
ans on s'est installé là temporairement
car c'est l'un des endroits où l'ennemi
a dit
tu les habitants vole leurs biens et
commettent de nombreuses
à 10 h au säntis
l'armée affirme avoir tué ici ces
miliciens au cours des 10 derniers jours
il avait attaqué le village de loi no
lille 12 janvier faisant fuir la
population sens et elle bloque des
maternités
descendre des centaines de lots nord à
l'intérieur tout a été pillé puis
détruits il était aussi le crépitement
des balles elle où elle gère aussi on
avait abîmé d'autres bâtiments de la
population quelque part là ici à obo à
ses jours nous sommes retournés l'on rit
parce qu'il ya la sécurité n'est ce qui
est elle
les luganais les phares et blessé 10
combo pour stopper ces attaques l'armée
ougandaise s'est déployée sur une grande
partie du territoire du nord kivu comme
ici dans le parc national des virunga le
responsable des services de
renseignement fait un point sur
l'avancée des troupes
les adf occupé à bien et comme biya
c'est là qu'était leur première base
ils ont fui mais au moment où je vous
parle nos forces sont sur place
pour prouver ses succès l'armée exif ses
prises de guerre un désaveu gdansk ce
sont les hommes que nous avons capturés
durant l'opération bonjour back in about
le colonel fait ensuite venir ses trois
enfants soldats capturés durant les
combats
ils ont 13 15 et 17 ans pour prouver
leur appartenance aux adm les militaires
leur ordonne de manipuler ces ak 47
l'échevine secours vous devriez être à
l'école nous allons vous ramener à
l'école ou back to school impossible de
voir les camps adf capturés mais l'armée
affirme écrasé les rebelles au sein de
la population certains sont plus
sceptiques et s'inquiète qu'ils ne
repoussent seulement les hommes armés
loin de la frontière ougandaise vers
d'autres provinces congolaises
ce soir on vous parle d'un projet la
mise à la disposition au grand public
d'entretiens inédits réalisés avec des
acteurs de la guerre d'algérie un projet
par portée par le réalisateur françois
demerliac il est notre invité bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous bonjour alors
tout d'abord parlez nous de votre projet
quelle est son origine et quelles
étaient vos motivations pour pour le
mettre en place
ça fait quelques années que je travaille
sur le sujet en fait j'avais commencé
par faire un film sur sartre en 2004 2
et 5 et puis ensuite un autre sur sur la
fée road 1 et puis encore après parce
que en fait j'ai dit qu'en faisant ses
films j'ai découvert mon ignorance sur
la guerre d'algérie comme beaucoup de
personnes de mon âge puisque c'est un
sujet dont on ne parlait pas à l'école
et au lycée donc ça m'a donné envie d'en
savoir plus et donc j'ai rencontré pas
mal de personnes qui
dans les témoignages étaient importants
pierre vidal naquet bon josette audin
j'en ai parlé robert badinter enfin bon
et puis des femmes aussi parce que en
allant l'algérie j'ai rencontré des
femmes que j'ai interviewés qui m'ont
montré un autre aspect en fait de cette
guerre qui est je pense pas assez
assez raconter enfin bon et
en fait à chaque fois quand on interview
quelqu'un
on préfet on a une rencontre qui dure
peut-être une heure et puis après on va
picorer des petits bouts au montage ça
génère une certaine frustration
parce que on se retrouve avec eux
avec une perte quoi c'est à dire que
quand on discute avec quelqu'un pendant
une heure il ya des choses qui passent
et quand on saucissonne les interviews
on les perd donc du coup je me suis dit
peut-être ce serait intéressant en fait
pour d'autres que moi de voir une façon
un peu voilà l'intégralité et puis
d'autre part il ya aussi un aspect
patrimonial cerqueux il ya un effet de
génération je vois là nicole dreyfus m'a
malheureusement elle est décédée il ya
certain nombre de personnes qui
vieillissent dont les témoignages
deviennent plus accessibles et que donc
du coup il ya un intérêt à rendre
accessibles ces témoignages pour pour
tout le monde alors justement on va
écouter nicole dreyfus qui était à vos
quêtes de militants du fln et on en
reparle après quand des personnes
étaient interrogées la veille
il était rare de les retrouver vivantes
lendemain
et ça c'est un haut responsable de
l'armée qu'il a déclaré alors dans ces
conditions
la figure d'un revêt un caractère
emblématique
et défendre la mémoire dans nos d'un
rechercher la vérité sur la façon
dont il a été assassiné
ce n'est pas seulement travailler pour
rodin
mais pour tous ceux qui ont connu
des histoires semblables
et toutes les familles
qui ont subi leur disparition et qui les
pleurent encore aujourd'hui nicole
dreyfus avocate de militants du fln il y
à de nombreux témoignages et témoins
dont l'interview sera sur votre
plateforme quels sont les plus connues
celles qui vous ont le plus touchés
les plus connus sont pas forcément ceux
qui m'ont le plus touché mais bon donc
je parlais de de pierre vidal naquet
josette audin mais il ya aussi des
personnes comme yessef sadi
bon et puis des des personnes moins
connus comme par exemple des soldats du
refus comme jean clavel ou des
infirmières du maquis comme buy out a
donc cédé personnes dont le perdant le
parcours et le la ville et les raisons
de leur engagement sont vraiment
importantes et et à ses actuelles un peu
c'est quand on voit ce qui se passe en
ukraine il ya beaucoup de parallèles
faire avec la guerre d'algérie
et là par exemple
et puis c'est des combats aussi qu'ils
sont pas forcément terminée quand
nicole dreyfus parle des disparus de la
guerre d'algérie pour lesquels
maurice audin est un peu personnage
emblématique il ya toujours des
recherches il ya un site qui s'appelle
mille autre point org qui a été recréée
par les historiens malika râler et
fabrice risque outil qui met en ligne en
fait et qui propose au public de
compéter décidé d'apporter des
informations pour les retrouver il ya
l'association josette et maurice audin
qui essayait de poursuivre toutes ses
actions et puis qui décerne à prix de
mathématiques des mathématiciens
français et algérien dans une optique de
d'amitié franco l algérienne pour
essayer justement de passer à travers
enfin d'essayer de passer au delà de
cette violence en fait qui appuient peut
occulter les débats alors il ya un film
justement qui sort demain dans le
maghreb du film qui retrace la vie de
fernand yveton de nos frères blessé un
fernand yveton c'est ce ce militant
communiste français qui a été guillotiné
parce qu'elle avait posé une bombe qui
n'a jamais exposé qui n'a jamais causé
de dégâts et il ya un film justement qui
sort et vous avez réalisé des interviews
à ce sujet aussi oui j'ai rencontré
plusieurs des membres des combattants de
la libération qui était le réseau en
fait la branche armée du parti
communiste algérien laquelle faisait
partie
à fernand yveton donc des personnes
comme abd el kader guerrouj qui est le
numéro 1 en fait de la série de parole
france algérie qu au met en ligne la
et puis d'autres femmes aux williams
sportif avant d'autres personnes qui
étaient proches de dijon et qu'ils
partageaient les mêmes les mêmes valeurs
en fait sur la bombe il faut préciser
aussi qu'elle était réglé pour sauter
même si elle avait sauté elle n'aurait
tué personne parce que c'était ne roule
hula o l'usiné était fermée donc en fait
il a été condamné à mort alors qu'il
allait tuer personne dans les salles
françaises à avoir été guillotinés
pendant voilà c'est le seul français est
en fait j'avais discuté bah y'a pas
longtemps avec à la russie au qui est
historien d'ailleurs des petits
interview de lui ainsi que coke en
publie en même temps dans lequel il
explique que s'il a été condamné s'était
aussi à titre d'exemple sert pour
montrer aussi aux militants
anticolonialistes européen le danger qui
avait engagé en fait auprès du flm aider
des anticolonialistes
alors c'est un film à voir
malheureusement on n'a pas beaucoup plus
de temps à vous consacrer j'aimerais
tout simplement que vous nous disiez
quels sont vos partenaires et vos modes
de diffusion alors bon c'est un projet
qui est
développé avec bombe à des associations
comme celle que j'ai déjà mentionné avec
aussi le maghreb des films qui à
festival off est qui qui fait connaître
des films algériens tunisiens
marocains aussi qu'ils sont assez rare
quand on a du mal à voir en france qui
sont extrêmement intéressants et donc on
a le projet en fait de créer une plate
forme de diffusion de contenus
audiovisuels donc des films des
documentaires des débats avec des visées
des banques qui peuvent être gratuits
comme la pole
comme
les conduites continue de place aux
dents en fait ce qui est une le web tv
que place audin point n'être point tv
sur la partie algérienne mais aussi
d'autres partis comme des films qui
pourront être téléchargement payant ou
d'autres gratuits avec l'idée que tout
ça rayonne et fasse une sorte de tunnel
sous la méditerranée merci infiniment
désolés on n'a pas plus de temps vous à
vous consacrer france pas de mérignac
merci d'avoir été notre invité c'est la
fin du journal de l'afrique tout de
suite vous retrouverez audry racines
pour la suite de paris direct
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'à ce jour à la scène nous avions
une réelle problématique de recrutement
pour les plombiers et les canalisateurs
lorsque nous faisions un recrutement
nous